not being safe on campus really affects
like how we perform in school because we
can't focus like we're waking up every
day going to campus where we don't feel
wanted we have people claim it they will
encourage us and kill us how can you
focus in that type of environment I do
think that it was a good call to call
out from 2012 when he was first I'm
putting to the position of president it
was like countless times that an
incidents on campus that he just been
addressed in a timely manner because in
his mind you know remember racism
doesn't exist that Mizzou because you're
not he wasn't in that situation to
experience the race